[Music]
how many keys are on a piano 88 that's
how many constellations there are oh wow
cool yeah so there's the twelve of the
zodiac
and the first three letters of the word
zodiac spell what zoo zoo so zoo it's
it's a panoply of animals creatures
uh people this sort of thing what i like
is that the sky has constellations that
are of things that are not even real
right there's like sagittarius is like
it's a centaur right and you know
chatters is half
man half horse we do have other ones
where humans are the rear end and the
animal is the front end but they're not
a constellation like the minotaur
minotaur yeah yeah that's the full head
bullhead human body and a human buttocks
right right some are mythical magical
creatures we have a flying horse which
is what pegasus pegasus is up there and
so it's fun to just see
where and when these constellations
started
and what legends what cultures what
mythologies put them on the sky and it's
not the same around the world okay if
you go to
australia
the aborigines who've been in australia
longer than any else anybody else have
been anywhere practically they have
their own legends and their own things
they say is up there in the sky like
there's the constellation didgeridoo
famous aboriginal constellation
and that other constellation boomerang
boomerang major boomerang minor
we've got
right so the thing is the constellations
tend to emanate from people's cultures
what's especially interesting in
australia is that the milky way which is
in full view most of the year at night
there are parts of the milky way that
are dark
and astrophysically we thought that was
the absence of stars so we thought that
these were gaps
in where the stars were in the milky way
we would later learn that they're simply
dark gas clouds obscuring the view
behind it
so we in the west tend to give meaning
to where we see light whereas in
australia
they saw those dark areas and they gave
meaning to the dark areas
so in fact one of the more famous of the
dark constellations if we may call it
that is what's called dark emu emu is
you know one of the creatures unique to
to australia it's also a a very popular
insurance salesperson here in america
yes it is okay
yes i forgot that was it anyhow so
depending on where you are in the world
they have different constellations and
different cultures and the like that's i
just want to make put that up up front
what we know in the west is what the
west has written about constellations
and that's what i'll spend most of this
the rest of the few minutes on so what
do we have uh we have sleepless
possibly
drug-induced
greeks and romans
and babylonians looking up into the
night sky
okay
i don't know what they were smoking i
don't know right but to see
four stars in the night sky
there's like a triangle and then another
star that's above it to look at that and
say yes i see a crab with two claws
that takes extreme imagination
or drugs
back then they called it pharmakia
that's what the creeks called it because
they were getting high so that that's
just an example
of
what
the foundation was for people then
dreaming this stuff up and so most of
the constellations that we see in the
northern hemisphere were seen by the
greeks and the romans and earlier before
them the babylonians and and so they
thought about it and they put up their
legends
okay so we have perseus and andromeda
and pegasus and there's even medusa not
a constellation but medusa's bloody
severed head is being held by perseus in
the sky
after it has been cut off why did he cut
off medusa's head to uh to turn the
kraken into stone yes
so that he could save
uh
what's her face
yes
to save what's her face
her face
pegasus was made from sea foam and it's
a flying horse not anatomically correct
flying horse because in the real world
you any mammal that flies
it forfeits its front limbs to be wings
to do so that makes sense and bats of
course gave that up so that's just how
that goes wow pegasus in the sky is not
anatomically correct that's all i'm
saying okay however are we really not
going to suspend disbelief for a flying
horse
correct so i'm not going to blame
anybody for giving pegasus four legs
plus wings all right they want them that
way fine i would say there's five out of
the 88 that look like what they're
supposed to look like and i'll give this
my top list here so orion the hunter
good to go maybe i'll give you hercules
but orion is a way better strong man in
the sky
than is hercules
uh leo
there's some stars that look like the
the the main the mane and the head and a
body that comes backwards i'll give you
leo so what are we up to three okay i
got one for you you ready go ahead um
there's
a constellation called
triangulum
okay
guess how many stars it has it better
have three
it's three stars
it is a most excellent representation of
what it's supposed to be that's pretty
awesome now how did a triangle slip in
with all these mythical magical
creatures it's because the greeks
couldn't see the southern hemisphere sky
and it wasn't until the 1700s where abby
louis
nicolas lacai i think i have most of his
names right he was a peripatetic i think
he was a monk actually but he went to
the southern hemisphere with the purpose
sole intent of mapping the rest of the
sky oh wow look at that yeah i know i
know so he so for the for the folks in
the west because of course in australia
they've been there done that millennia
earlier and
he's this is like late 1700s or so this
is the dawn of the industrial revolution
and he says to myself these other things
are important to me
not the greek and roman gods
so he lays it out and he names a sextant
oh god that is a that is a consolation
called sexton's it's a yes an octant
okay which preceded the sextant two
navigational devices are down there
right he has argo novice which is the
the ship for uh i think was jason and
the argonauts okay but so that's legend
of course but he has parts of the ship
he has a keel a mast a compass
this is a navigational compass all of
these are constellations there is the
two star constellation
telescopium okay
there's also a drafting table
okay
it's yeah it's called picture i think it
is it's it's someone at a drafting table
so the constellations are very different
depending on what era people absorb them
name them and put them in the books
what's in your mind the most famous
constellation in the southern hemisphere
oh in the southern
god see so what i was going to say but
that's not southern was big dipper but
everybody knows that yeah that's the
north yeah that's the new york okay yeah
you're southern eight thousand miles off
i know um
i said it wasn't that nice no nine out
of ten people say the southern cross i
was about to say the cross you did you
were not
i really was
no let me tell you something i really
was about to say the cross but i was
scared to do so because one night we
were sitting out and you had your
you know top secret uh sky pointer
government issue
and you were and you but there's a cross
in the north too yeah that you would and
so that's why i would i was about to say
cross but okay so there's a northern
cross which we love here in the northern
hemisphere and there's a southern cross
but they're really different from each
other
okay the southern cross is
embarrassing compared to the northern
cross oh no okay the southern cross has
four stars in it
okay it's in the shape of a rhombus
there is no star there's no at the
transept right yeah so you could have
just drawn a rhombus to remind people
from eighth grade geometry rhombus like
take a perfect square sit on it
distort the sides and then you get a
rhombus okay
so it is a stretch
to call the southern cross across
it's a stretch i'm just telling you wow
not only that of all 88 constellations
the southern cross is the smallest
oh
your thumbnail at arm's reach
would completely cover all four stars of
the southern cross oh
it is one of the biggest
marketing delusions there ever was and
isn't there crosby stills
uh song crosby nat um
that's the only one i know because it
has astronomically gonna say i don't
know this song at all buddy
or they didn't sing that in the hood
yeah i was gonna say csr that's uh you
know it's a little caucasian for me i'm
just saying
i mean don't get me wrong but you know
so this i just want to put put it out
there with the southern cross now
have you ever met people who have
visited the southern hemisphere anywhere
be it africa or australia right and and
they come back and what do they tell you
about the sky
uh i you know i never really got into it
i normally ask them about the place they
were see that's that's the clubs how's
that exactly you know tell me about the
food what did you see you know only you
would be like and so the night sky yeah
i'm sorry i'm telling you more about
that
what happens is people visit the
southern hemisphere and they come back
and say the southern hemisphere
atmosphere sky is so beautiful yeah it
is so amazing
oh my gosh
and
and so there's another little delusion
going on there as well
and what is that
i don't want to stop you from liking the
southern hemisphere sky better than the
north uh
i have no problems with that
but there are forces operating that
contaminate your data
okay okay do you know how much of
earth's land is in the southern
hemisphere
um i would say not a lot not a lot about
i mean when you look at africa it's like
that's most of it yes okay about 15
of earth's land mass is south of the
equator
okay that's also about 15 percent of
earth's population
okay
so hardly anybody lives in the southern
hemisphere right
so there's hardly any city lights
hardly any light pollution air pollution
all the things that subtract away from
our experience embracing the sky in the
north does not
block your view in the south so people
think the actual sky is better
because they can see it better
wow
so
i'm telling you
that the north has all the coolest
constellations
all right you know with the big dipper
and you know and the little dipper and
the you know and
and and cassiopeia some constellations
straddle the north and the south or ryan
is half in the north and half of the
south but when we look at him he's right
side up you want to see orion in the
southern hemisphere he's upside down
that there's there's no excuse for that
so i'm just i'm a northern chauvinist
here but i think i have good reason for
it daniel kolakowski was asking um about
your views on the current state of light
pollution around the world and if
there's any negative impacts on people's
feelings and perceptions about the
knights what do you have in it
so we always light pollution
i'm going to start there i'm going to
say yes i am very concerned about light
pollution i've done a lot of work with
the international dark sky association
and the idea is that
from an indigenous
practice and way of life
uh this the sky in our connection with
the sky
um it's an essential it's not an option
it's not an accessory
it's uh the place where we come from the
stars are not just
physical distant abstract balls of
plasma or gas
those are our relatives our oldest
living relatives and you know we even
have in lakota there's teachings that
the the stars at the breath of the
spirits you know so it's not it's about
like a family reunion it's blocking that
level of connection
every distraction that
exists in modern living that distracts
us in the evening
isn't that tan amount to light pollution
you know we have hbo and disney plus and
and netflix and all these things i come
home
and my first thought is let me binge
something or let me watch a movie or let
me watch nadine
doing a stand-up not a sit down a
stand-up
aren't you also competing with all the
rest of these cultural forces yes
absolutely we we are very distracted we
have very short attention spans we're
looking for the next fun thing but the
there's something really important and
fundamental about our connection to the
stars um and that there should be a
place for that there should be a kind of
protection for that i know that with the
international dark sky association there
we've you know created this uh
protection protected areas because we
talk about the extinction like the night
sky is going extinct
and so you know here in minnesota it's a
luxury because we can drive you know
5-10 minutes and really see dark skies
we can really see
uh the andromeda galaxy we could really
see the northern lights right i mean
you're in new york city wow i really
feel bad for you we have yeah
we have a planetarium right
yeah we just we just we just uh huddle
together
in the planetarium dome and put up the
fake aurora and the fake uh that's what
make you feel at home yeah yeah
can i just say in defense of myself
though that my stand-up is not the enemy
of the cosmos if anything it's squid
game
so
let's just like you know
note where popular culture is right now
come on just blame something else
instead of yourself okay fine but you
know annette i actually i grew up in the
desert of southern california in a town
called palm springs and they have very
strict light pollution laws so i live in
new york city now where in my estimation
we don't have stars um but in palm
springs we have a ton of stars i grew up
with uh seeing a lot of scars be stars
because they were very serious about
light pollution with your astigmatism
very clearly
with my astigmatism and i'd often see
them there's
there's two there's two of everything if
you look at it through my through my
eyes jay hunt
asks i was wondering how indigenous
tribes constellations identification and
sky tracking has changed over the
centuries what are some of the more
famous constellations that have made it
into the modern lexicon oh interesting
so the changes over the ages i think one
of the biggest things to say about that
is the idea of
loss
we've lost a lot of our star knowledge
in our cultural knowledge and our
languages because of colonization
in the star maps that we created you
know working with elders and other
primary sources
there's a lot of like blank spaces and
my in a new elder wilford buck
he talks about the idea that
um you know
before colonization that map would have
been filled up just like what we think
of now as the greek map it would have
been dense you know every single
star and even the dimmer stars there's
constellations but now we look at our
constellations and there's there's some
spaces and that's part of that loss so i
think you're bumming this out here
the farthest object visible to the
unaided eye
is a galaxy
beyond the stars of the constellation
andromeda
so you find a drama in the sky and
there's stars and then there's like a
fuzzy patch
right okay the stars you see are just
sitting on our nose in our own galaxy
the milky way the fuzzy patch is well
beyond this
two
million light years away wow okay you
can see it because there's so many stars
there and the light is but you can't
resolve it so it's just a puddle of
light in fact it wasn't until 1920 no
that edwin hubble the man not the
telescope
put his telescope on this fuzzy patch
and resolved it into stars
okay so before then people just called
it a nebula it was like the andromeda
nebula they thought it was just a fuzzy
cloud so
that this is why what things look like
to you aren't always what they are all
right so
he does this and you realize it's an
entire other galaxy that galaxy is
visible to the naked eye
so
that galaxy
has
200 400 billion stars in it
right so if you want to
if you want to think differently about
what the human eye can see you take your
3 000
that are in our galaxy up there and then
add to it the hundreds of billions in
the andromeda galaxy which you can also
see
wow look at that and in that case when
you look up if you include the andromeda
galaxy in your field of view you get to
say you're seeing billions of stars
again billions and billion will this guy
look different if we are all standing on
another planet
constellations and such so if i'm if i'm
on another planet in this solar system
do i see the same sky yes
what
you heard what i said you said yes
yeah so here's it's a simple answer okay
so the extent of our solar system is
like from like the sun
to
neptune
get over it
no if you look at the planets so so it
says
so basically we're such a small exactly
right exactly so you're not going to
change the frame of reference exactly so
if you look at the width of the solar
system it's like 10 light hours across
okay it would take a beam of light 10
hours to cross the solar system that's
big that's a long time especially going
to speed of light right
however as you look at the nearest stars
the stars that comprise the
constellations they are hundreds of
light years away gotcha so if you just
shift your head 10 light hours who you
know the stars don't mean nothing they
don't mean a damn thing that it's ours
so you got to start moving among the
stars
to change your
perspective on the constellations for
them to take on other shapes and drag
all the astrologers with you as they try
to keep up with the new shapes right
okay and tell you how the universe will
now affect you right because of the
random stars oriented in the galaxy that
one looks like someone looking at a
cloud what will we call it
[Music]